good founder has to have has to have a
lot of
dedication and enough of flexibility to
be able to reinvent
itself this is the for me this is the
difference between the
you know companies that are successful
in companies that are you know go
nowhere
[Music]
levy rice thank you so much for joining
me how are you thank you thanks for
making this happen it wasn't easy i know
i i it wasn't easy but but i'm so glad
and that we made this happen with all
the difficulties in the scheduling and
you know i believe that you mentioned
after one of our msfs
you know if if it's really difficult it
means that it's really really good so
i'm i'm going with that mindset into
this
uh maybe let's talk about investments
these 20 minutes and you know you've had
the privilege of sitting on numerous
positions with venture capital funds and
you've seen countless entrepreneurs and
and i'd love to sort of pick your brain
from your experiences on the on some of
the key insights that you've gained
whether it's about
the type of person you like to invest in
or how does the whole pipeline look in
your mind
or what entrepreneurs should be doing as
they're
approaching the fundraising so levy i'll
let you take it from here
tell me maybe a little bit about
yourself and where you come from okay
let's let's start with that so
in uh a few words about myself um
you know i'm in vc for the last eight
years before that i've been
doing uh building companies myself had
four
four companies so far you know you know
two of them one
one of them actually succeeded and i
sold it the
second one is also success and still
exists and working
i mean uh making money and a few other
ones i just
miserably failed so that was my so i
kind of learned
in what order by the way what was the
order yeah it was
it was success it was the
failure uh second kind of success
and then uh then a failure so
the uh i like that i like the zigzag yep
so i always say it's better to
it's better to fail fast so and then
uh rather than you know kind of drag it
out for for years
uh so that's you know uh that's that's
my professional career and
uh eight years ago i've been
privileged to be invited to join one of
the vcs to become a
partner in the species we've uh invested
a lot of
a lot of companies here in israel and
i've done you know been
privileged to do some great investments
and some really bad investments
uh now this they know these days i'm
with the
with digital horizon vc we are an early
stage
uh firm i'm venture partner dealing with
all the
all the deal flow uh in israel
and you know i'm uh 34 married
uh to another beautiful entrepreneur we
have three kids
who are also probably look like they're
very entrepreneurial
uh that's that's me you know that's me
hey what differentiates between the good
investments that you've
made and the bad investments the really
good ones and the really bad ones is
there some
pattern recognition that you now
understand looking back at the
few that succeeded in the future that
didn't succeed i think the uh
yeah i think you can i can find some the
you know there are a lot of factors that
are
kind of objective and you know sometimes
it's great team
great technology and there is some just
you know
objective factor you know the mark time
marquee timing is wrong or something is
you know there's something
out there that is not dependent on us
which doesn't work that happens all the
time and that's normal but
you know that's why we invest that's why
it's called venture capital we take race
with the other cases you know where it's
more of a
you know people's issue i i would say
that the you know the dedication
of founders mixed with flexibility of
their
kind of mindset is that what i found is
a
crucial crucial things what i mean by
that
you know there a lot of you always
trying to invest into the dedicated
founder
but the when the this founder is very
dedicated
and has no flexibility and it's just
going you know straight
you know straight ahead you know hitting
the mountain
uh head to head sometimes it doesn't
work and you need to be
flexible enough to accept this and to
you know not go and just like uh you
know
be completely broken but reinvent
yourself so those companies that
succeed or invent themselves right those
are the good ones
the ones that kind of you know hit the
wall
and can't reinvent themselves those are
the ones that you know
uh kind of die die off so that's that's
the main difference i would say
the good founder has to have has to have
a lot of dedication and enough
flexibility to be able to reinvent
itself this is the for me this is the
difference between the
you know companies that are successful
in companies that are you know go
nowhere
but how do you measure flexibility when
you do you know a
let's say a three week due diligence
process you meet the entrepreneur four
or five times
how do you how do you measure an
entrepreneur's ability to be flexible
because you're also you're
right you're you know funding in the
early stages right when you're
essentially investing in the person how
do you measure flexibility so yeah
that's that's actually a great question
because you know this is something that
uh it takes
took me at least time to to learn and to
figure it out
i uh in in real life what matters when
you go and you know you meet a person
and when you actually have a more deeper
conversations when it's not just a pitch
and you know they're just like pitching
to the company you're saying
you know what do you think and so on and
like in when you actually have a deeper
you know uh deeper conversations and you
meet the whole team and you see the
dynamics
between them you see how they actually
interact
do they because usually usually people
have a very different opinions
an early stage if there is a strong team
there are always strong opinions
and there are two ways of kind of right
those companies to
to work sometimes it's just a clash of
opinions
and in the end someone just says you
know what like okay i'm the ceo so i'll
decide
and uh things are not heard much or
you know in other things you can see
that right it's very you know it's a
very slight difference the ceo
is the final decision decision maker
because that's what you want from a ceo
but you see that he might be completely
disagree
with the with the other opinion but
he'll still consider it
so the slight difference if you feel it
that there is
i think this is a good sign it's not a
guarantee but it's a good sign that
there is enough flexibility in this
person and you just something you learn
from those two three weeks of you know
having conversations i've
for example i had a
several occasions where i had to find
kind of pull
out the term sheets when we already got
to the point when it wasn't you know it
wasn't the first date or second date
when it was kind of
you know we started you know our
relationship like
to to the next level and you
like right before signing the term sheet
you see that the person is just
you know lost that's it like his
flexibility ended after like a
third meeting and now it's like he's
completely or she's completely
inflexible
and that's where i usually pull out if
that's how that happens
right no i think i think that's that's
really interesting and
so how many investments would you say
you've you've
seen or played around with in your over
your company you know
i have a portfolio of 25 plus companies
that i actually you know like my teams
and i invested
the overall i would say probably over
you know over over this eight years
probably
several thousand companies and you know
honestly
to be honest like that i actually like
dug in
deeply i would say it's probably
maybe five seven hundred i don't know a
lot a lot of you know like a lot of
companies
these years
so so what part of this of the cycle of
the
of of venture capital would you enjoy
most
personally so there's so many different
moving pieces right and anybody who's
gone through a cycle of fundraising
knows that
you know they're it's like a big roller
coaster both for the entrepreneur but
also for the investor from the deal
sourcing to the diligence to the
decision
to then supporting the portfolio company
it's a whole balagan so so which part is
your favorite
uh so the favorite part is really
is uh is it some kind of a exit you know
that's the favorite part for everyone
and when everyone is you know happy and
usually it's after the
hard like kind of you know hard
track of difficulties and all kind of
things happen
sure now you're asking about like more
like early part you know there's a joke
between with pc's pc say that the
you know the the fun is over when when
you actually wear the money
you know that's one so the the part
before that yeah the whole
kind of getting to know the company
meeting the entrepreneurs getting you
know getting it really
kind of into what they're doing uh and
being you know getting to know the
entrepreneurs this is i think this is
the funnest
uh the funnest part this is the most uh
enjoyable part
and specifically sometimes you just
click with the with the founders with
entrepreneurs you know and you
so for me this is the the people ability
to kind of
you know be become a part of their
journey and
be you know be helpful to them and
you know meet kind of meet their world
because
like you meet those very very exciting
people
who are like you know they've done
things they they're they
they're doing things they're dreamers
you know they're executioners
and you you kind of you get all this
energy this is the most exciting
uh exciting part and also that's where
you decide
for yourself how you can actually be
helpful to the company like what you can
actually
uh deliver you know a lot of you know a
lot of funds a lot of
vcs say you know value add and like what
you
you know i'll make introductions i'll uh
bring your you know more and more invest
help you raise money and so on
so you know that's something that a lot
of you know
small like a lot of things a lot of vcs
can do because everyone comes with
some kind of you know background and so
on sometimes
it's you know what it's when you connect
to the
ceo and you actually feel that you can
help the ceo in specific tasks like you
know
the ceo comes to you and says like you
know hey bro i need
i need help with like hiring this person
i like
i can't like i can't feel this position
for like for a while please help
like help this is what that's what kind
of makes you
you know feel like you're really part of
this company when you can solve
specific issues and not just be you know
like another person to make
introductions
no no that makes perfect sense so if
you're not looking at you know young
entrepreneurs that are starting their
journey perhaps they
they've never raised money from vcs or
they're now you know they're reaching
new rounds
that they haven't reached before so what
what
advice would you give them as their as
they're thinking both in terms of
you know growing and scaling the company
and you've seen some companies scale
with the in your portfolio
or you know in terms of their
communication with the venture capital
partners
the um okay that's a good question
you know i would say
i would say you know the first of all it
has to be you know
you have to realize that the raising
money is not easy
you know it's just not it's not a simple
process and it's
there will be a lot of discouragement
like you know discouraging
moments when people will be saying you
know you'll get
no off you know and also you will get
multiple completely contradicting
opinions from
from smart people right you know you go
to
one smart pc and he tells you like hey
well like you know you're doing all this
wrong you
believe you have to do x y and z and
you'll go to another person and he'll
tell you like completely opposite thing
so you have to be able to
focus on you know what you do and
you know be kind of again flexibility
listen to the people
get their feedback you know adjust a
little bit
but keep your keep your core don't like
you know just don't
don't go and change your you know what
do you do
from like meeting to meetings that's uh
you know
that's one that's one thing how do you
balance that
so how do you balance when yeah you're
approaching two different vcs both
very reputable but they're they're
giving contradictory ideas
and you're you're sort of in the middle
uh
because the whole power struggle at that
point is
the vc is more knowledgeable they're
assessing your
validity and if a vc tells you that
you're doing something wrong
then you're questioning yourself another
vc says you're doing something right
then now you're confused
as to how to approach this so i think
you know i think first of all
the you know the kind of
by default like by definition i wouldn't
say that the vc
is the you know more knowledgeable or
smarter than you
the vc is another enterprise or
hopefully another entrepreneur who is
just in a different stage
in his life and you know that's the
the someone who if we see the good vc is
looking for
a ceo for the company who is a leader
who can lead this opportunity
vc doesn't want to be like it doesn't
want to lead this thing
like he did like it's not you know if i
would be smart enough i always say
say no like to the entrepreneurs i'm
saying
guys you know if i would would know this
better than you so i would probably
start this company
you know like why why why am i investing
here you know because
i trust you and your in your
your judgment so i think that's the
point that's the point you have to be
there's a very thin border between you
know where
very thin line between being stubborn
and uh kind of being done next is being
flexible isn't and next is being
you know completely all over the place
so
you like i would say this flexibility
when you do know what you're doing and
you do believe
in what the way you chose but you
understand that you
probably do not know all the details and
there are other people who have
experience that you have to
acknowledge so that's when it creates
the the healthy conversations and you
know sometimes
vcs you know the great vcs have wrong
wrong opinions you know every grade we
see
but i'm not even so great have a you
know like uh anti
anti portfolio where they missed all you
know a lot of good companies
you know so that's sure uh this always
happens
right i i think that almost every vc
that every
venture capital partner that i met in
silicon valley so far has
this crazy story of how they passed on
airbnb or
lyft or or one of those one of one of
those great companies when they were
young
and and now and then they reflect and
they're thinking okay why why did we
miss them
and it's not like the vc knows
everything and that you're able to
assess
um amazingly the validity of the company
you also miss
um a good friend of mine passed on
airbnb yeah
so uh yep that's that's the reality
definitely
so now
exactly now you have young entrepreneurs
that are that are looking to meet you
for for example that are that are
raising money
what what kind of you know advice like
just you know seeing a lot of other
companies would you give them
specifically saying
these are the things that you should be
focusing on the in the early stages of
your company maybe it's to go
full throttle on on fundraising or maybe
it's to find some balance and how do
they how do they look for the right
investors
what are some things that that you that
you think are really important
so you know i always always ask this
question myself as
also you know as the entrepreneur
because you know i
you know i've raised money before for my
for my companies
and you know hopefully you know if i
start other companies i will probably
raise money again so
it's hard to you know it's hard to judge
from the position
of the uh of the vc but uh i think like
when i kind of i'll i'll speak of myself
you know when
uh when entrepreneurs come come to me in
the early stage
they you know first of all i
i look for the i look for the
acknowledgement that
i like they don't know any everything
you know when people come to me and they
start like
laying out you know three-year plan with
like you know details and this i'm like
whoa guys you like
you haven't you know really started yet
how do you know what's going to happen
then
you know and the my point the answer is
we don't really know but that's what we
expect and that's what we're getting
we're going to you know
go go for but uh so that's
right the idea is the you have to
build you i want to see that the
entrepreneur
thought through a lot of things
really deeply and they understand the
challenges the problems and
unknowns that they have in the way so
that's when i became
while keeping in mind that they don't
know everything yeah because that's
exactly you know when
uh because it's very
very strange to see an early stage
company like i see company
comes to you and says you know we're
gonna like we have this five pilots in
three months
we're gonna close you know those five
clients and so on so and i'll
so what happens if you guys don't close
yeah
so i would say i would say that they're
being realistic
you know and being visionary but at the
same time being realistic it's a lot of
contradicting things
is something that kind of specifically
speaks to me right
i think it to me it sounds like you're
looking for the visionary and having the
humility
of knowing that while you might be a
visionary it's
quite possible being visionary doesn't
contradict being open-minded and
understanding that the vision can change
according to the circumstances right now
you have
information x or you have x plus y
that that's a new world right there now
you have to be visionary again
and another very important the crucial
thing is just you know
like know know your stuff meaning
you know i mean when you speak to a ceo
that you know gives you this
you know the product it usually happens
when the ceo is a product person not
really a business person
you know you have a very deep
conversation about the you know about
the product and what it does and what
we'll do
and vision how it's going to change the
world and change everything
i want to get get to the like hard
numbers and just okay so let's talk
about how we're gonna have make it
happen right that's when it starts you
know
oh you know this is like my other
co-founder did that and like i don't
know this number
you don't have to know everything but
you have to be able to
operate your you know your your excels
and your financials
uh like the way you're actually you know
uh
if you that you have it in your mind so
that's what very it was very
gives you confidence about the about the
ceo
and about the co-founders
i think there's a growing misconception
almost that
people believe that they're coming in
for a for an interview
like the vc is going to ask them as if
it's on shark tank they're asking
they're going to ask them for these
numbers and they're testing their memory
to see whether they're serious or not
but that's not that's not how it works
you're when you ask somebody for a
number or like a forecast for something
it's not
to test whether they've memorized the
number it's too
it's an actual question and and if they
give off a vibe that they're not control
they're not
owning the information and they don't
understand the process
of that maybe the other co-founder has
done it's fine that they did
that they did the work but you need to
understand the process and be able to
take ownership of it right if you're if
you're representing the company
yeah and and so i think that that is an
interesting
element yeah yeah that's a great element
it's just important because they
exactly what you said you want to see
like you want to understand this number
like you here's a vc as a person who'd
you know done business yourself
you understand that you know there is a
very high probability that those numbers
are incorrect
for all different reasons but you
wouldn't understand that the person
understands how how this actually forms
how that comes to life and you know and
if you
if the person understands it then you
can say okay this guy actually
knows what to expect and he'll be able
to react or that you know
right so that's that's what you want to
do exactly
i love it libby this has been so much
fun unfortunately we have to end 20
minutes or 20 minutes or over but i have
the most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
i've been waiting for that that's the uh
so you know first of all thanks for
giving me heads up for this and
you know i've been actually able to
think about it
so the i would say this i would say that
uh i think here when i think about
myself i think that you know
about curiosity i happen to be
a you know uh very
i would say none uh what's the word in
english the uh
like uh
none like i don't you know i don't like
following the
the herd i don't like following the
crowd so
yeah and uh yeah and the last thing i
would say
are probably pretty entrepreneurial
which sometimes
actually is a negative to be for to be
vc because you're like to
get too passionate about things and
you're you know instead of
cold mine outside you become one of the
heartbreak like heartbreak
inside
lady thank you so much this is really
great uh
stay safe and stay healthy until this
yeah let us all you know let us all
uh more come out of it you know that
better and stronger and healthier
people you know make god help us all
just to
you know go to to stay safe
through all this thanks thanks
thanks for having me